[Musik]
antreten im verteidigungsministerium
heißt es am dienstag für die
heeressportler dominik landertinger
simon eder bernard sieger
stefanie brunner und karin unter
wurzacher bei verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner
[Musik]
die unterstützung durch das bundesheer
war für alle heeressportler in den
vergangenen jahren von entscheidender
bedeutung
das bundeshaus für die wichtigsten
sachen kraut für leistungssport des
bundes jahr gab es 5 prozent für die
leistungssportler und trotz absicherung
für junge athleten und so war es bei mir
zwar 212 dabei habe ich immer super
unterstützung kriegt und wollen immer
sehr gut versorgt und da kann man nur
dank um die unterstützung von bundesheer
war definitiv die grundlage bei der
leistungen ohne bundesheer würde es
meine erfolge meiner karriere wie die
vieler anderer sportler gar nicht geben
um den beruflichen weiter gang braucht
man sich keine sorgen zu machen alle
fünf blicken hoffnungsvoll in die
zukunft oder jungen sportlern die
schulische laufbahn abgeschlossen heute
ja da war das mein großes ziel das sie
zum bundes endlich dürfen und als profi
biker starten kann und jetzt einige
jahre später bin ich wieder sehr froh
also dass sie das bundesheer mir die
stange heute und dass man in so einer
krisenzeit einfach zusammen weiter
arbeiten und die zukunft schaut euch
sportler und darüber hinaus also in
einer sportart wie oder wo man nicht
viel preisgelder kriegt und nicht so
viele sponsern hat ist das bundesheer
die einzige möglichkeit den sport auf
einem gewissen niveau zu machen und ich
bin sehr dankbar dass sie mich so viele
jahre unterstützt haben und mir das
ermöglicht haben meine ziele zu
verfolgen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
betont einmal mehr die wichtigkeit des
heeres sports innerhalb des bundesrats
die zukunft des her sports ist gesichert
ist unglaublich wichtig es ist für mich
persönlich auch wichtig
ist mein anliegen tatsächlich auch das
sicherstellen zu können dass aus
trainiert weil sie haben darf und was
man sich auch sicher sein kann für seine
berufliche zu
[Musik]